he wrote directed and star
in the madwoman's ball based on the
novel by victoria mass can you
tell us a little bit about what drew you
to this film to bring the pages to the
screen with your your wonderful adapted
screenplay thank you
um i was obsessed at that moment in my
life
uh about telling a story about feminism
but i didn't want to call it feminist
and
i wanted to avoid that as a main subject
i wanted to find something
more powerful and
not making feminist being like the
center of everything and
and i was working on a beginning of a
script who who was talking about the
witches in in the middle age and and
that producer ella goldman uh
called me and say hey i i have a book
and and and i just want to
i just want to
i just want you to just tell me what you
think about it and then i found it so
amazing
amazingly structured and everything was
there already in the book and i thought
oh my god that's great but i also
realized and i was horrified that
my witch story in the militage was kind
of like the same under on you know like
underneath the subjects and i was like
oh my god there is
any any centuries you pick you're gonna
find like exactly kind of like the same
horrific story about women
right right and your your character is
tormented you know and she she's raised
to believe in the science um and but can
you tell us a little bit about what she
discovers in that scene that moving
scene with her father um and how that
changes everything for her
i think uh
i think genevieve is very rigid and but
also very generous and and she's she
really believes in science and she
really believed that she served that
hospital and that she
she can count
and she doesn't see that she's
humiliated every single day she doesn't
even
see it and
and then she's in a deny she she she
cannot recover from a
loss
and that loss
makes her miserable except that she
doesn't want to see it so the minute
urjin is gonna
just
looking at her differently and just like
give her the possibility of thinking
about something bigger
and and and just open her mind and her
spirit and her heart just a little bit
more and she's and she go for it she
totally goes for it and and that's the
beauty of that character who's totally
ready
to let go
who just needed a friend and she
just needed someone to teach her
right and she she risks everything
including her own freedom to help
eugenie escape the institution and
and you know
it's just so but i don't know if she i
don't know if she lost i don't know if
she lost her freedom i think she i think
she thinks she's free and she's not and
i think she's
sacrificed herself obviously
for her
to do good things in the world and to be
proud of that but
i think she's she's free at the end
right
and how do you feel uh you know being
back at the toronto international film
festival with this film
i mean i'm so happy and honored and
and it's pretty amazing to do
i feel like i have everything you know
i'm on a big platform who's gonna
release my movie in almost 300 countries
but i also screen in a big international
um festival so
i feel extremely lucky
and as you know um a woman filmmaker and
tips share her journey movement you know
how you know especially impactful this
film is about the abuses of women in the
the 19th century like it's such an
important film to bring to the festival
cool thank you well it just seems that
sometimes i feel like we in in in the
big revolution we started three years
ago
uh
i feel like we
kind of like
forgot a little bit of certain women in
certain countries
and and i feel like we finally in our
jobs
have maybe a voice back and some space
and
some respect even if it's forced there
is more respect
but you know we left behind those women
in afghanistan we
we still have a
indian uh woman uh who suffers and and
been raped every four seconds uh in
india and and there is so many
big huge countries who has like
wonderful beautiful woman who who
doesn't exist and who doesn't
who's not free and who suffers every
second so at least the minimum we can do
as free woman who finally has like the
possibility of having money to make
movies and and to tell stories is to
just you know to tell stories about
those women and to never forget them
you